voilà du monde il y en avait ce week-end
à paris en tout cas pour les deux
concerts des rolling stones 164 1000
personnes en deux jours ils seront
beaucoup moins nombreux ce soir à
l'olympia pour entendre mick jagger et
les autres un concert beaucoup plus
intime mille cinq cents privilégiés dont
vous êtes éric perrin oui vous le voyez
les derniers des mille cinq cents
privilégiés qui vont pouvoir assister à
ce concert sont en train de rentrer
alors je vous propose tout de suite de
prendre un petit peu le coup de
l'ambiance avec véronique barondeau de
ce concert mythique avant même d'avoir
eu lieu car l'olympia c'est une salle
que les stones connaissent déjà
je vous pose de voir le conte le sujet
on va y aller ensuite on va y aller on y
va
on a fait une nuit d'échappement visite
des gars sort c'est un super il y avait
une ambiance bonne enfant et des tic a
fait les croissants on est sympa de voir
que des gens pour que la nuit du tout
tenu le stand génial tous les gens qu'on
a vu repartir avec la haine hier on a
vraiment l'impression d'être privilégiés
quoi pas de néons comme à l'habitude
l'affiché sobre mais deux poids 1500
personnes tout munis de leurs billets du
bracelet qui prouve qu'elles ne l'ont
pas acheter au marché noir
le règlement est strict bracelet déchiré
entre est refusé non j'ai billets qui
correspond et ne rien savoir
et pendant ce temps là à l'entrée des
artistes
mick jagger arrive à l'olympia un chemin
qu'il connaît déjà 1967 l'aéroport
d'orly les stones débarque en france
pour leur troisième concert à l'olympia
d'ailleurs mick jagger keith richards
912 la fois les lunettes le
psychédélique
sous son chapeau le mythique brian jones
à l'époque leurs bagages sont
soigneusement fouillé par les douanes à
la recherche de quelques substances
hallucinogènes
mais trente ans plus tard c'est surtout
de cette salle olympia donc qu'il se
souvienne je me souviens bien de cette
sage le maintien il ya des endroits
comme ça où vous sentez qu'il ya eu une
aura particulière ce spa chocolat à
l'époque on est venu jouer pour la
première fois les têtes d'affiché tel
attrait pour maurice chevalier voyageant
grands stars se produisent là c'est un
endroit unis ces citations 1970 palais
des sports mick taylor a remplacé brian
jones retrouvé mort dans sa piscine
c'est l'époque de tous les excès celle
aussi où le groupe sont à merveille où
se forment ce qu'on appellera leçon
stone
durant toutes ces années chacun de leurs
concerts provoque des émeutes l'image
sulfureuse et révolutionnaire des stones
s'amplifie 25 ans est passé le concert
de ce soir sera probablement moins
tumultueux il ressemblera certainement
celui qui le jour donné dans un club
d'amsterdam et un mois et pour les
inconditionnels c'est dans ces petites
salles qu'il sonne comme dans le passé